[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 82 of
the weekly Google Club app from podcast
I am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mendel that is finally
back welcome back mark I am back Thank
You invested well fed well to bagged
it's not too bad okay it's very good
really good
awesome well we are here this week to
talk all about prometheus that is cool
and not only we going to talk about
Prometheus but we actually going to talk
about it with one of the creators Judas
voles so he's gonna be joining us from
Berlin and tell us about what is
prometheus if you don't know what it is
it's basically a monitoring system it's
open source yeah that is completely open
source and completely raining go so yeah
I knew you'd like that
fantastic and then after we've done that
we'll have a regular question of the
week where we're talking about logging
where you haven't logged before yeah it
that's not a very Star Trek yeah so yeah
logging like when you have not written
any log statements and now it's failing
in production well help yep so we talk
about that use case and how we can help
with that but before that we have as
always our cool things of the week first
one that we have and I'm gonna I keep on
writing this in an order and then going
over the things in a completely for an
order but I don't care because the most
exciting one for me is that we have a
new region that has been open for Google
Club puffin and it is the Singapore
region which is very exciting I have
never been to Singapore yet but there's
gopher Khan Singapore so I'm Michael
next year nice this is going to make it
so the round trip for a Google Data
Center in Southeast Asia is going to be
much much better so of course Singapore
but also if you think about places like
Indonesia there's going to be a huge
huge difference for them so very excited
about that yeah it looks really really
good
always glad to have more locations we
seem to be growing them a lot lately
which I'm super happy about yeah yeah
cuz it makes for more reasons to travel
around and go visit places so that's
exciting
I mean because he helps our customers
that's what I was yeah wonderful
um so going on from there one of the
ones that I particularly liked in the
machine learning space is we recently
talked about and announced the release
of the tensor flow object detection API
so the cool thing of a week is actually
tutorial about how you can use this new
open source framework that makes object
detection much easier so if you want to
be like hey that thing's a car or that
thing's a dog or that thing over there
is a fire hydrant okay I don't know
anything along those lines sure this is
a tutorial that shows you how you can
use that framework but specifically
tying it in with our cloud machine
learning engine are scalable fully
managed service for doing this kind of
machine learning stuff and it's a really
nice step-by-step example of how to do
this and how to build it all with
tensorflow but particularly what I love
about it is that it uses what's the
exact name for it is Oxford the Oxford I
don't know why it's the IIIT but it is
basically a pet database so anything
that involves you using dogs or animals
I'm totally for so you get to look at
cute puppies and stuff while you're
actually training your tensorflow model
I really like that they show a picture
of two beagles and one is a 99% beagle
and the other one is 98% beagles
wondering what is like what is the big
list big old thing I'm fine what clearly
the one on the left is the big list
clearly yeah I love tensorflow
and the examples of the head they use
they're always hilarious very loved it
finally we have a third hosting of the
week and needs solution from our
solutions team that is preparing a
container engine environment for
production and this is really cool
because it doesn't like creating a
container engine cluster is incredibly
simple you just go to the forum click a
button that's it or even from J club so
it's super easy right but that doesn't
mean that you should open that directly
to the world and just hope for the best
there's a lot of different best
practices that you should follow like
from the point of view of like I am
there you go I am what are what are the
rules that you should be providing what
roles to the machine should have what
roles you should have and things like
that how to protect the machines using
all the
firewalls and stuff like that basically
it's mostly about security but it is
very important and it has very concrete
examples so if you have a container
engine cluster running in production and
I would even say if you have a
kubernetes cluster running in production
most of these best practices definitely
apply to you so go check it out and let
us know what you think yeah it's really
good guide on a whole lot of things
through from our back and I am through
do like how to do communications for
your data center to your cluster and all
sorts of other stuff from there so
definitely worth having a look at if you
do not know what is a headless service
you should read this because it actually
explains it because I didn't know what
it was so if you don't know what it is
go check it out it's actually an
interesting thing that might help you
have a better life in production boom
all right well why don't we go chat with
our friend julius and have a talk of all
about open source monitoring with
Prometheus sounds very good led to that
so I'm very happy to welcome today
Julis volts the Prometheus co-founder
hello Julius how you doing hi I'm doing
great thanks for having me and you're
joining us from Berlin today yup nice
weather here 6:40 p.m. the whole week
will be very nice and sunny that is
awesome I met you long time ago I think
it was the first talk prometheus ever
gave at the go meet up in Berlin - yup
yeah and direct it's it's been a long
time so we're gonna be talking a little
bit about Prometheus and what it is and
everything but before we we talk about
that tell us a little bit about yourself
and what you do at Prometheus I guess
the company is also called Prometheus or
is it sampler aha so there is no company
that's the trick
no so yeah myself so I was a Google site
reliability engineer at some point in my
career and then from Google went
straight to SoundCloud from Zurich to
Berlin and at SoundCloud we started
building Prometheus so that's what I've
been doing for the roughly like past
five years or so I left SoundCloud
roughly one and a half years back and
then started doing just you know
freelancing around
prometheus Prometheus is the monitoring
system that is really independent by now
it's part of the cloud native computing
foundation which in turn is part of the
Linux Foundation kubernetes is the was
the first project in there and we're the
second and so it means like there's no
one company that controls the project
there are companies that offer services
around it but they're not like the main
Prometheus company and SoundCloud
doesn't even care that much about
Prometheus anymore although it was born
there okay so let us talk about
Prometheus at a high level what is it
what does it do what's its purpose right
haha
so Prometheus is a systems monitoring
toolkit slash ecosystem some some years
in the past there were systems like
Nagios graphite ganglia stat steam union
and so on some for collecting time
series some for running checks to
actually send alerts to people and of
course these tools still exist and they
have their uses but they were created in
a world that was way more static than
the worlds the the infrastructure worlds
that we have nowadays where you have
clusters like kubernetes cluster
managers that schedule instances and
pods dynamically moving around scaling
up scaling down and so Prometheus is a
monitoring system that was specifically
built for this kind of dynamic cloud
environment where these things are
shifting around all the time and you
still want to try and make sense of
things and we started building
Prometheus really because so this was
back in 2012 met proud and myself
joining SoundCloud both coming from
Google having seen how you can monitor
dynamic environments and then being
thrown into a start-up basically
SoundCloud which already had a dynamic
environment they had a static dynamic
cluster scheduler but they still had the
old kind of monitoring tools and they
were ok but they weren't really cutting
it anymore for this kind of scenario so
it was really difficult to find out for
example if there was a latency spike was
it only one instance was it multiple
which instance was it
the dimensionality of graphite wasn't
really sufficient the alerting and
alerting expressiveness and data model
of Nagios and the lack of any history in
Nagios to alert on was another problem
and prometheus was really inspired by
Google's approach to monitoring and
takes an approach of let's collect
everything that we care about in our
infrastructure as a set of metrics as a
set of time series first and then base
any dashboards and alerts based on these
on these time series and to allow you to
to make that powerful enough we also
basically added a query language to
Prometheus that is quite flexible that
allows you to work with the data that
you collected and formulate really you
know powerful expressions against the
data to slice and dice the data
aggregate up drill down depending on
what you need in that moment cool
so to give similar context and maybe
peace those people who aren't as
familiar for like monitoring and stuff
could you give it an example of like
sort of step by step through what you
would be setting up and why you'd be
setting up and how would that work with
Prometheus there's there's so many
different ways I could set things up
prometheus is really kind of a Swiss
Army knife of monitoring but let's say
you have let's let's start with a simple
case of we just want to gather host
metrics or node metrics then we could
install a little component called the
node exporter which is a little agent on
every machine and it will basically
fetch metrics about the machine itself
from the parentheses FS file systems and
it has a little HTTP endpoint over which
Prometheus the server can scrape metrics
from that host so you set up a
Prometheus server and you tell it here
are all of my hosts that I care about
that I want to monitor and it will then
go out to these node exporters and we'll
pull in in a dimensional data model all
these metrics so they will be they will
be tagged with something we called
labels
key-value pairs on every metric that
tell you what service the metrics came
from what exact instance in the service
and then what other kind of sub
dimensions they pertain to like the
exact CPU core for CPU usage or so on
and then from there you can do stuff
with it right so Prometheus stores that
prometheus is a pull based system it
pulls those metrics from things you care
about like node exporters but also your
services or other things stores them as
time series on disk and then you can use
that in like three different ways I
would say either for ad-hoc debugging
you go to per meters itself it has a
built-in UI for trying out some
Prometheus query language prom ql
expressions where you can really inspect
the current state of all your
infrastructure and once you have
expressions there that you might want to
dashboard you can use a tool like
profiler to talk to Prometheus HTTP API
to run the exact same queries and have
nice persistent dashboards that you can
share with your team throw on the wall
and so on and then the third use case
would be alerting where you can reuse
the same query language for actually
formulating really precise alerts
against the data you collected so I
might be able to set something up that
says like if my CPUs been at 95% for
five minutes then send me an alert
because something's going wrong on the
server or something like that exactly
yeah and you can do you can do things
that are not even strictly threshold
related so for example in Nagios you can
only really say something like you know
if this check script fails three times
in roll then alert me and you don't
really collect history first that you
can then do more analysis overwrite it
doesn't collect any time series data
with Prometheus you collect basically
you know some amount of time series data
and you can do some more time based
analysis on it for example you can say
something you know based on the last
four hours of the disk usage tell me
whether my disk will be full in four
hours or so and then a lot on that I say
so sort of predictive analysis type
things so some
the limited forms of predictive analysis
there's no automatic anomaly detection
no no kind of magic there but it's
explicit rules explicit functions that
allow you to go quite far so that sounds
really interesting from the point of
view of like all the features that it
offers but I'm curious about how it
actually runs so you mentioned that it
is a pole base system so do you have a
server that is pulling every single one
of the jobs does that mean that you need
to install an agent every single one of
your jobs what does that look like ok so
it does mean that you do have to have
HTTP endpoints that you can scrape if
it's a piece of software that you cannot
instrument directly we typically have
these things called exporters that are
little bridges that sit between
primitives and the thing you care about
and translate the metrics into the
primitives format so you already
mentioned the node exporter which
translates this in progress metrics into
Prometheus metrics then we have for
example a my sequel daemon exporter that
in the back end talks actual sequel
queries to am a sequel daemon and gets
internal stats about that server and
translates that to Prometheus metrics
and we have you know by now I think over
a hundred of these integrations in both
you know in our official organization
and provided by the community and
they're pretty easy to write they're
basically just small translation layers
between metric systems and then the
golden thing like the what we really
recommend is if you have services
yourselves
that you build yourself where you
control the code really instrumentum
directly using one of the client
libraries that we provide where you get
API objects such as a counter a gauge
histogram or summary that allow you to
track various states in your own service
and exactly the ones that you actually
care about so really nice white box
instrumentation of your code and that's
really you know that's that's we how you
can also get the best alerting so I'm
curious about something you mentioned so
basically the way I understand it
Prometheus goes in and outs and goes and
scrapes these HTTP endpoints on all the
different things that you have running
outside but we're also you're also
talking about very dynamic environments
so something like kubernetes we're
containers going up and down or possibly
environments where VMs are being created
destroyed
constantly how does prometheus know when
those things have spun up or been
destroyed so it knows to go and grab
that data from where it needs to you
thank you for the great question this is
one of the key parts of primitives that
make it special I would say it
integrates with service discovery and
with whatever kind of service discovery
your infrastructure has these can think
out of we out of the box we currently
support roughly 10 different mechanisms
so these can be ones where you discover
AWS or not easy - or Google compute
engine instances or so on on the host
level but we also integrate with some of
the cluster schedulers like kubernetes
where we talk to the kubernetes api
server to provide us the list of all the
services endpoints and pods and so on
running on that kubernetes cluster and
the nice thing is this kind of serves
multiple purposes
on one hand we know then where we need
to go to get metrics so you know the
actual HTTP endpoints on the other hand
we know what should be there in the
world and if we cannot pull from it we
know that it's down you can base simple
health alerting on this already on the
signal and the third thing that which is
really cool is if you're using a good
service discovery mechanism like the one
in kubernetes for example you get a lot
of metadata about the things you
discover so you don't only know that
there is an HTTP endpoint that you
should pull from but you also get all
the kubernetes annotations and labels
and other metadata that you can then
choose to either map into your time
series or also make decisions on you
know like you can have an annotation
that says whether to scrape a target at
all or not yeah but for example you're
just mapping the the metadata into your
time series is very nice because then
you can see this engine x over there is
an environment equals production
instance for example and then you can
use that in your queries in your alerts
so yeah the service discovery
integration is something that is pretty
new in monitoring systems and has been
ignored in the static world I mean
static world you kind of just configure
what you expect or often with push based
systems where the instrumented services
themselves push metrics to the
monitoring system the question of what
even should be there in the world has
often just been ignored you know like if
an instance or a host never reports in
you might never know that it's missing
so I have a couple questions now you
keep on saying this word time series
over and over and I'm curious about it
on one side you say that you expose that
times here is that that data from every
single one of the elements that you're
monitoring what is the format for that
is that like Jason protocol buffers how
do you expose that because I guess that
is very important that that that's
efficient right yep
we had Jason at the very beginning of
Prometheus and then dump that at some
point for not only but also efficiency
reasons now we have two formats a
text-based one which is very simple to
construct a nice to read and very
efficient to parse where basically you
like the format contains one sample per
line one time serious sample per line
and we also have a protocol buffer based
format which is even it can be even more
efficient and a bit more robust and can
then easily be implemented by any
protocol buffer passer but in reality
they are not actually many
implementations that need to parse the
protocol because it's mainly the
primitive server doing that job so we
really want to optimize the easy
production so that you can easy even
from a shell script really easily just
spit out a metric and so on so the text
format seems to be the one that actually
is gaining the most traction and some
client libraries don't even bother
implementing the protocol buffer format
at the moment and then so you're part
you're getting all the information from
a lot of different agents and I'm
assuming that that's going to be a
decent amount of data that you want to
store somewhere where do you store it
what is the data base behind all of this
right yeah parameters data is highly
dimensional you're not only getting from
a lot of sources but those sources might
sup differentiate their own data by a
lot of labels and dimensions
what CPU that the CPU uses which happen
in you know what mode did it happen in
and so on and so on which filesystem did
some file system fullness metric pertain
to and we store all the data currently
on local disk Prometheus itself only
knows how to store local disk this is
intentional because it keeps things
simple you don't have to run a clustered
distributed system which might be the
first one that goes down in the face of
a network partition or some other
trouble when you need your monitoring
system the most the next question then
is usually but how do you keep that
highly available the way you do that is
by just running two identically
configured primitive servers that know
exactly nothing about each other take
just you know they're configured to
scrape exactly the same targets there's
no history or there is any kind of
historical states and targets the
targets really just know the last value
of any metric so what the current value
so you know you can scrape them in
parallel by as many primitives as you
want and it still works out fine and
then both of these servers can calculate
alerting routes by themselves and
dispatch alerts to a component also of
the Prometheus ecosystem called the
alert manager and that then actually
duplicates these alerts and routes them
to recipients so that does mean that the
local storage isn't infinitely scalable
or durable if you lose a node it's gone
and you know if you had lose two nodes
and turn and they come back up they
won't backfill from the other so for
people who do want to store data for a
really long time with a guarantee of not
losing it we recently added a remote
write and read back integration protocol
that people can integrate with where
Prometheus basically sends any sample
that it stores also to a remote URL that
you can specify and optionally if your
bridge implements it you can also then
read back the data so for example right
now we have a experimental toy bridge
which knows how to write data into in
flux DB which you can get in a clustered
version in a coma
version at least and then also read it
back again through prom QL in Prometheus
but coming from in flux DB so now you
can loop your local database and still
get data so yeah but we really wanted to
decouple the actual really core alerting
functionality from that remote storage
aspect yeah this really sounds like a
good match for for BigTable yep I like
to see if someone could implement
something like that that'd be cool well
this is this is happening already so
there is also an cortex from we've works
which is both an open source project and
a hosted service by them which I also
was involved in building and this is a
re-implementation of Prometheus based on
currently AWS but another company is
working on porting it over to Google
cloud also BigTable they're based by the
way and this is multi tenant
horizontally scalable durable forever
and so on and you basically configure
your Prometheus locally to still
discover targets locally pull targets
locally but then send all the collected
samples over to this cloud service or
you know you could run this yourself as
well so yeah that that kind of already
exists or is being created very nice
very cool so I'm also just curious it
looks like there's a huge community Ram
Prometheus who's actually using it can
you name any customers oh I have to be
careful I would have to look any
spreadsheet to see who I can name
publicly there are a bunch of fortune
500 companies big ones I think Walmart
labs has been recently reasonably open
New York Times yeah several big ones
other ones are thinking about it I guess
South SoundCloud is using it I don't
want to name any names that I shouldn't
name at the moment so I would have to
check the list again to make sure that
I'm just I'm just looking at the website
oh yeah the website has some that
explicitly asked us to add their logo
but there's many more and really big
ones as well yeah so I mean I think one
of the nice things for the adoption of
Prometheus was that it also works really
nicely together with kubernetes so
kubernetes is kind of really inspired by
bork in google there was a tool inside
Google which basically I mean I think
it's mentioned in the Google as an
e-book called Bachmann and that was a
big inspiration for Prometheus so
there's some analogy going on between
kubernetes and Prometheus they both use
labels in their data models kubernetes
has Native Prometheus metrics Prometheus
has native support for parameters F for
kubernetes service discovery so they
kind of go together well and I think a
lot of ex schoolers and current Googlers
also notice that and picked it up
because of that reason so I think that
really helps adoption as well as as well
as being part of this cloud native
computing foundation also there there's
something else that is in common between
kubernetes and Prometheus right which is
they're both winning go
they're both written and go yes single
static binaries yes yep
Hey just just because I'm super super
curious as well
so if I want to install Prometheus on
kubernetes should I install it in the
same cluster that I'm already running my
other apps in or should I run it in a
different cluster like mark for me feels
yeah like who monitors the monitors
right yeah I think what people normally
do is they do run their normal
Prometheus in the kubernetes cluster
because that makes it easier to monitor
targets in there you automatically get
the necessary credentials mounted into
your kubernetes pod to be able to talk
to the API server and so on and you also
have immediate network access to all the
instances in the pods that you need to
pull from you can and should if you're
serious about monitoring then still have
some external metal monitoring
probability that monitors your
Prometheus servers not only that they're
up but the parameter server itself also
outputs a lot of instrumentation in the
parameters format about itself so now
you can really inspect with some meta
monitoring you know how all your
primitive servers are really behaving
whether they're overloaded and so on
yeah and I'm curious about since you
were talking about things that are in
common between kubernetes and Prometheus
one of the cool things about kubernetes
is that idea of having many kubernetes
clusters working together as a
federation is there such a thing for
monitoring or is it not necessary we
have a concept
all Federation it's not exactly the same
as kubernetes Federation the way it
works is that you let's say you have 10
data centers or 10 kubernetes clusters
you might have for a given service in
there or all the services run one
parameter server per cluster that gives
you a very detailed local view of the
universe but it might be that not all
the data of all ten clusters fits into
one big global parameter server so you
could have still a federation set up
where you have a global parameter server
which scrapes federated data from all
the tens of ordinated parameters but
only gets kind of roll outs or
aggregations where you maybe sum up over
all the instances of a given service and
and don't have the really detailed data
anymore so you can keep that global but
not really detailed level at the top and
have local but very detailed data at the
bottom of your Federation tree and your
Federation tree could even have multiple
levels you can also use Federation to do
it kind of sideways you know to pull
data from a Prometheus of a different
team if you're also interested in that
common use case would be for example if
the kubernetes the team that runs the
kubernetes cluster has a primitive
server and you have maybe your own one
that just monitors your your direct
service metrics of your one service
running on kubernetes you might be also
interested in externally observed
container resource usage metrics for
your services right so you could pull
them from the other parameter server
that is already gathering all that data
from there built and see advisors in the
cubelets and then store that in your
parameter server or you could also if
you have the credentials even go out and
you know scrape that data yourself but
that's one possibility as well so this
this allows you to scale setups and be
more flexible so I guess we're kind of
running out of time but is there any
other topic and anything that we have we
might have missed that you'd like to
mention
I should probably mention that there is
has come conference happening again this
year the second one prong come the first
one was last year in Berlin and the one
this year is going to happen August 17
and 18 in the Google Munich office yes
nice and the CFP is currently still open
so we're still taking talks until the
end of the month
head to prank 100 and submit a talk if
you do anything vaguely Prometheus
related that could be interesting and if
you just want to attend we are going to
open ticket sales probably sometime in
June awesome well Julius thank you so
much for taking time to hang out with us
talking to us about Prometheus I'm
definitely going to take that for a spin
sometime soon that was really
interesting
they're all so much thank you I really
want to sit down and play with
Prometheus I think I'm going to install
it on some clusters that I'm using so I
can see exactly what's going on inside
them I'm yeah it is a really cool
project and I really like that it's open
source so you know it's like if you have
a cluster of machines running anywhere
but you can have now kubernetes yep with
G RPC and East EO and Trinity for
meteors and everything is waiting go so
you know yeah it's a happy world go so
let's move on to our question of the
week right yeah so this is this is a fun
one so the idea here being is that I
built an application and maybe I forgot
to add some logging in some places that
I probably should have fret something
went wrong maybe I was a bit rushed who
knows right and something's failing in
production and I'm thinking to myself ah
I really wish I put some logging in
there but I mean ideally I mean I could
just rewrite the code and redeploy a new
version that takes time it takes effort
I'd prefer not to do that is there a way
I can magically just stick some log
statements inside my code and make it
run no you should have written better
code is your fault and you should feel
bad no it is I'm sorry there's actually
there's actually a great way we talked
about these long time ago but from the
point of view of stackdriver debugger
yep which is a really awesome tool that
works on most environments in most
languages exit4 go on App Engine other
than that pretty much works everywhere
so if you
using no J's or Python or Java or go you
should check it out probably works I
probably works it works so what you can
do is you can go and set a breakpoint in
the line that you care about you want to
learn more about what are the values of
all the variables at this point if you
did this for real like you actually put
a brake on then you're actually stopping
and processing production and that's a
big No yep so that's not what happens
what happens is that we take a snapshot
of the whole stock call stack and the
heap so you can actually see out what
are the variables well the values for
every single one of those variables now
the problem is that if you do these what
you're getting is every single time
there's a new snapshot you get to see it
and you inspect it manually right and
sometimes it's not what you want to do
sometimes what you want to do is see a
log of not only once but like all of the
times that someone goes through like in
an actual log so then you can analyze it
with all the log analysis tools that you
might already have and I can see the
history and like exactly what's going on
so it's actually very useful right so
literally everything you can do
everything you want to do is just add
one line of logs and you can actually do
that it's what we call debug lock point
and it is as simple as going through the
debugger clicking on the line number and
rather than adding a breakpoint what you
add is a lock point and then you can
write a little it's basically a line of
code that basically says if some
condition then log some expression
that's it it's very simple but that's
exactly what you want super effective
there's a really good video by our dear
colleague hammer Lee it's one of those
clap minutes so in less than 60 seconds
you learn how to use it
in her case for Python but it is pretty
much the same case for every language
pool so now I can add logging statement
anywhere I want inside my execute code
actually yeah I mean then there's the
point of like at what point like because
those logs will be there but then when
you redeploy the go away yep but then
should you have the log in your code
base I feel like I feel like this is
stuff I will put in in an emergency and
then go back and review what is the
writer
of logs to have in my thing so that in
future cases maybe something else goes
wrong or similar thing goes wrong I can
track it yeah
once I've done my post-mortem and my
blame free analysis and all that kind of
stuff
Blayne free analysis that the important
part cool so I guess that that answers
the question and these almost the end of
the episode but before that so you're
finally back
I am what are you up to so I'm staying
in San Francisco for a while which I'm
super happy about a little bit of travel
less but it looks like I'm going to be
at next New York on the 18th of July
nice I'll be talking about gaming and
GCP details to be determined but looks
like that's going ahead so that should
be lots and lots of fun this is gonna be
related somehow to the blog post that
you wrote on how to run video games and
kubernetes and stuff like that it's
entirely possible at this point actually
I'm not sure I'll say yeah in this case
is normal you say it's its secret it's a
great secret it's confidential
okay yeah and if I can't I can either
confirm not tonight excellent and what
are you up to just for Frank stuff yes I
just publish my latest just a funk
actually a publisher because I was so
late in the previous one the ended up
going up almost together but yeah one it
was about CEO and the the one that I
published like last week and it's a
really cool one running a Twitter bot
winning go we systemd and Google cloud
platform for free
nice yeah so it was like we talked about
all the free tier and stuff like that a
couple times
everyone micros are free and they're
tiny but they're big enough so yeah it
is it's a pretty cool episode and then
after that I'm actually preparing my
workshop for go tooling in action that
will take place in New York for Q Khan q
can New York which is in two weeks so
that is the last week of June which is a
week up to the 26 I'll be there for the
whole week it's gonna be awesome
awesome well franceska thank you so much
for joining me for yet another episode
all right thank you Mark for coming back
finally I hope your dog is happy he is
very happy thanks to all our listeners
as well and we'll see you all next week
see y'all next week
you